[Music]
this week in feminism
[Music]
i had a job
and then i didn't show up
no i don't
[Music]
come
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
channel
[Music]
is
[Music]
no we're still alive i don't need to go
under my desk
perfect no nukes just making sure
because i don't know if you know this
but when there's a nuclear fallout this
solid block of pine
that's all this guy needs um and a mask
yes
well we need a n95 mask correct yes an
n95 mask because of the uranium
particulates that's the primary concern
there we're going to be talking about
potential world war iii but before that
we'll also be talking about today look
this doesn't exist in a bubble russia
and ukraine
i think a lot of people are missing not
only how this affects you but american
how domestic policy here specifically
domestic energy policy regardless of how
you feel about native americans or
climate justice
how it affects the rest of the world the
rest of the free world and the rest of
by the way the oppressed third world one
of the greatest things the united states
can do for people for example in places
like india or places anywhere pick
anywhere in south america developing
countries
is use our own resources is access our
own energy production not only that but
it's also pretty important that the
united states dollars uses the benchmark
and uh
that could go away soon and that could
affect everybody so before you're eager
to go off to war and this is what we see
from the left and the right on the media
today let's ask ourselves right now it's
hard to get the numbers thousands of
people dead in the ukraine terrible your
heart goes out to them do you want that
number to be a billion that's the risk
reward that we're looking at
not to mention the deaths from
skyrocketing energy skyrocketing energy
prices but before i go on any of that
this is a live show monday through
thursday 10 a.m eastern if i don't tell
you that we are not doing a show
that means we're still doing a show
we're just not on youtube so you can
watch it on rumble or you can join mug
club littlesquatter.com we're doing an
additional 45 minutes today discussing
uh vigilantism as it relates to
pedophiles not ex not
advocating exactly not at all
but kind of advocating but not
advocating not advocating not advocating
no no no that's right we want the
pedophiles to be set free no bail
required and we want
the vigilant the pedophile vigilantes to
be jailed with no bail allowed so
my question to you first off how pissed
off are you about gas prices
second if someone molested your child
would you shoot them
if you were on the jury
would you find the man guilty who tried
to shoot him that's just teaser
questions i just questioned they
wouldn't dump several gallons or 38
dollars worth of gas on them no you
would not
kerosene is cheaper at this point i
think i don't know exactly zippo fluid
yes zippo fluid i think uh dave's a
little bit low but first uh before i
bring in uh mr linda we have gerald a
how are you sir i'm well how are you sir
i know you're fired up about iran oh
well just a little bit all of the
international stuff is like really
important to me it's kind of in my
wheelhouse yeah i love it when we get
back into bed with terrorists for oil
when we could just do it ourselves oh
that's foreshadowing
you steinbeck you know and then we have
them here you know you love me you can
follow him on twitter at landau dave
dave landau how are you sir ahoy and you
i'm fine you look like you're going you
look like you're a 90s uh skateboarder i
took my hat off and everybody was like
look at that hat hair and i said it's
magnificent so i'm rocking it you look
at 90s bully like
yeah punk you want to go
take it yeah straight out of paper boy
yeah boy i know right i bet you're gay
do you mean paper boy the canadian
rapper no no i meant the game no that's
drake the half jew from westmount who
couldn't outrun the school shooter in
degrassi
he's a tough hooligan that drake old
wheels mccaffrey yes
very different everyone else is bragging
about their wheels he's bragging about
his actual wheels they only have to buy
one pair of cool shoes right
and then as he gets older he's bragging
about his tennis balls
before i move on to that uh it's also by
the way international women's day which
is thrilling yeah yeah
do they celebrate that in saudi arabia
they beat you harder yes so
but celebrating women before we move on
to that we do need to celebrate the
beautiful and brave women here in the
united states um
i'm not even sure whose side this lady
is on exactly but she seems primarily
concerned with two things
as she uh
clearly becomes or displays i shouldn't
say become because she was already
certifiable long before this displays
her certifiable insanity two things see
if you can catch them black lives matter
[Music]
your what
take a guess
[Laughter]
like the hob goblin in spider-man 3
my [ __ ] matters toby
she's wrong nobody wants that at all no
certainly not the black lives she's
championing no it doesn't matter like
black lives matter yeah modern
no we don't want that ugh
what's your was that thing in the
clearance bin you don't don't tie them
together don't make us guilty by
association with that clam
what was she she must have broke i don't
know she must have broken at least
twelve dollars worth of merch yes
exactly she's well under the 999 minimum
easily well i thought you could steal it
i didn't think you could just smash it i
don't know look i'm i don't understand
the technicality but at that point once
you grab it it's yours
you do whatever you want make whatever
claims yeah i think that's how it works
was she bowling
what are those were those pumpkin
candles that's what i couldn't tell i
think they were candles she's offended
by candles that's fine she just went to
the clearance rack she's like i want to
commit a felony here but i don't want to
vandalize the uh yeah the in-season
candles let's stay away from the st
patrick's day let me grab the pumpkin
and valentine's day candles well she was
looking for the gwyneth paltrow vagina
candle to fool somebody she was having
over later yes and completely out of
stock yeah she tried to light that
candle wafting like a pie and yogi bear
she thought all the black guys were like
no not um on the windowsill
the fish gotcha
all right so it is international women's
day uh you know this it's international
women's day it is fantastic that's why
we led with it huh
uh and uh i don't know if you know this
but in previous years uh women have
actually they went on strike i don't
know if they're doing that this year
they did it last year the year before
that where they went on strike to show
people what a world without women would
look like remember that last year yeah
and um
shocking turn of events that dow jones
was up 500 points hr complaints were an
all-time low traffic was smoother than
ever before everyone was using their
turn signals
crazy it's amazing so let it never be
said that you cannot make a difference
but uh there
were some complications there there were
some still primary issues where men
didn't realize how how good they had it
slightly dry
[Music]
we need that lady with the candles be
careful what you asked for okay you just
might get it when's the international
men's day i'm against all of these days
uh it's called gay pride month no no no
no win straight pride month yeah there
is no straight pride month that's the
problems like women have their women's
only gyms curves yeah if guys do it it
just becomes a bathhouse with fouchy
guys have uh man tits it's not a bad gym
right you just don't want to be seen
walking in no you also don't want to see
them freeing the nipple ah yes that's
dangerous daddy jiggles yeah free the
hairy areola that's swollen from years
of xenoestrogens and sodium
well international women's day i don't
know how we celebrate it uh oh no that's
right we don't so
i do want to celebrate some men
uh cain velasquez is a ufc fighter now i
want to be clear we're gonna have to
talk about this on mug club today so if
you are here on youtube i recommend and
nothing would make me happier than more
of you to go over to rumble and mug club
unfortunately we have to be here on
youtube they've been messing with their
channel for a while we know that we
don't make a dime on youtube so please
consider doing that we can't talk about
this
topic yeah because it's controversial to
get the warm fuzzies for uh a man who
tries to um shoot
the molester of his child yeah
so we have to be careful to tread
carefully yes it reminds me that song
you know if you're loving who's wrong i
don't want to be right well
we're blaming hollywood that's where's
tip or gore when you need her oh well
i'm putting someone you're going to put
it on for run dmc and not that sh so
i think you have too much gain on my
microphone are you hearing that it's
kind of clipping me a little bit or a
little bit too much compression so
kane velasquez are you good there keegan
yeah we got raining pretty heavily oh is
that what's happening it's raining sorry
it's storming here who'da thought that
in texas in spring mostly men so kane
velasquez in the ufc uh he's the ex-ufc
heavyweight champion and this is a story
that's been making the rounds i want to
be clear i knew about this uh last week
and i didn't want to discuss it publicly
because i did have a little bit of an
inside lane and now some of this
information is publicly available not
all of it i will tell you
the more information that is going to be
made available
the worse it's going to be not for kane
but for the uh pedophile in question and
i do think that this creates an
existential question for a lot of people
i know that we live in a society with
laws and we don't tolerate vigilantism
but we also live in a modern society
where unfortunately uh for the first
time ever in human history
child sex offenders aren't killed on
site
they're barely punished they're barely
punished and we'll get into that
specifically where in this case the
child sex offender
was let out with no bail required and
the father who tried to take out the
pedophilic trash was put in jail with no
bail allowed
so let me just um i think we have a clip
uh cain velasquez the man whose son i'll
give you that quick rundown his son was
molested at a daycare molested by a guy
who didn't even work at the daycare was
a daycare in a house allegedly 100 times
we don't know how many other victims had
been assaulted by this man
and uh what happened was he was taken
and he was booked right he was charged
and then they said you're going to go
home on house arrest against the advice
of the d.a who said this is this
person's a danger this person is
molested many times sexually assaulted
children many times and they were going
to get his ankle bracelet this dad
whose child was effectively raped
sexually assaulted
did take justice into his own hands
chased the car down and fired into the
car ended up hitting the dad about
non-fatal wounds that's the story
there's more to it which we'll discuss
on mug club but here's a video of kane
velasquez appearing in court where he's
being denied bail on attempted murder
charges in california at a hearing in
san jose a judge denied bail for
velazquez who's been charged with
attempted murder assault and shooting at
an occupied vehicle police say velasquez
tried to shoot harry gallarte who's been
charged with molesting velasquez's
four-year-old brother who could have
guessed daycare owned by gallarte's
mother
authorities say velazquez also chased
gallarte and his parents at high speed
from morgan hill to south san jose
before ramming their truck twice and
again firing shots at them two bullets
hit gallarte's stepfather who is now
recovering the shooting and chase
happened three days after a different
judge freed gallarte from custody on
supervised release over the da's
objection that looks like it could be uh
joseph rosenbaum's doppelganger to be
fair i mean much king lester was
following instructions he was repeatedly
screaming shoot me inward shoot me it's
the catch phrase pedophile don't say it
if you don't want it yeah you know i
mean i mean careful what you wish for
exactly
we never say chase somebody down and
shoot them that is don't do the old
story of the pedophile monkey paw right
or the map
dora's gonna be a stripper
yeah it makes sense that there's a
revolving door for a pedophile yeah yeah
he is the one that has to stay behind
bars yeah that's wonderful and look can
you comment but before we go to mug club
there's a hashtag free kane is going on
right now and he's his legal defense
fund has been taken down can we at least
all find common ground that the dad who
in a moment of i can only imagine with
two
two small uh children babies toddlers
whatever the appropriate age term is i
don't really know i can only imagine the
rage if someone can plead temporary
insanity committing yeah a murder
against innocent people can you not
allow for temporary insanity or at least
a temper flare-up when the guy finds out
that his kid has been molested 100 times
that the guy is getting off scot-free at
that point
at least until he's convicted
i mean the whole point right where you
deny bail what they're doing with cain
velasquez is you deny bail to someone
who's who's a danger to society at large
right like someone who molests a kid a
hundred times yeah california sees this
guy
as a danger to society at large the only
person the only car he ever fired upon
was a car carrying a pedophile that's
true if there are more pedophiles around
maybe he's a danger but i don't know
yeah nobody that enlisted his child yeah
i mean he's the most dangerous guy in
the convention yes exactly yeah well
disney's there they don't want to put
everyone in jail no exactly that's a
good point
so uh hashtag free kanes and if you guys
want to show him some
i can't say show him some support if you
guys yeah if you guys want to show this
man some support at least he's not the
monster that the pedophile is can we all
find common ground on that that a dad
who commits an act of violence against
someone who sexually assaulted his child
is not the same kind of a monster as the
man who committed the grossest act of
evil that i can imagine does it get much
more evil than that no
no it actually doesn't it's worse than
murder but it's treated as nothing right
that's what i don't understand about our
society right now yeah all right we'll
talk about and i would yeah we should
wait and i would never say that i wish
he was a better shot no i would never
and i would never say that you know what
this guy was ufc heavyweight champion
everyone would be better off if he'd
have dragged him from the car and beaten
him with his fists well i'm just saying
end feet not that you should he could
have submitted him
why that's not fun
you'd submit your drunken uncle at a
cookout you don't submit a pedophile
we'll talk about it later you throw some
elbows because you don't even honor the
unified rules
how many cookouts have you ruined
my uncle
you know i'm not an uncle yet well so
you're not no i'm not that's it's what i
said i wanted my burger medium you
should be an honorary uncle i could be
an honorary uncle but i'm not now uh by
the way also better.com
tour yeah to go see us live uh colorado
springs june 18th is sold out but
we'll probably be adding a show we're
working with your venue right now tulsa
oklahoma may 14th me and dave on tour
stand up and uh also some uh
some sketch comedy some improv county
but both doing some uh stand up uh
speaking of performing uh the
performance arts kanye west so he's been
in some hot water um always
and more recently because of his music
videos
where people were
upset that it seems like and again it's
art so not everything is literal
but people were upset this was trending
this weekend that he
allegedly was burying killing pete
davidson in the video now i have two
minds about this i'm not entirely sure
here's the clip
a clip from the video that you've likely
seen
[Music]
that's the same motorcycle in which he
was straddled uh right
true song was equally bad
now to be fair i don't really know
that's not necessarily about pete
davidson they claimed that he was
burying pete davidson because pete
davidson is dating uh you know kim
kardashian yes also hip-hop is now
sampling hip-hop right
it used to be like you were grabbing
from the spinners you're going through
the temptations now it's like kanye is
sampling jay-z who's sampling kanye yeah
it's insane it's the inception of
low-grade hip-hop it's really something
it's it's annie
yeah jay-z and it's gone
but to be fair though
if you actually look at and again i
understand art needs to be given
permission to
explore explore the space
that being said if you look at the
extended version
some people would argue
that it's
i mean as far as it relates to killing
pete davidson that it's pretty cut and
dry and we actually have the exclusive
it hasn't been released
yet from around the way
i wanna kill davidson
you're just talking about pete davidson
killing all i wanna do is dig a hole for
pete davidson not tell us that's
davidson here talking about killing
davidson literally not figuratively
davidson yeah literally not figuratively
i want to kill pete davidson put him on
a table kill him literally because i'm
able
[Music]
i don't know i'm on the fence yeah he's
an artist and who am i to interpret the
lyrics come on man it's a song about
pete davidson it's art well you're going
to take all art literally now it's a
song about pete david i don't know he
didn't even name pete davidson more than
four or five times yeah
and by the way pete davidson could be
figurative i mean he says it's not
figurative but that's art as well he
could be figuring he could be saying
it's like when people say literally and
they don't mean literally yeah they do
mean literally he was holding ahead of
pete davidson he was holding a
claymation head that resembled bore a
vague resemblance dave well it was
striking
striking
it was a claymation pete davidson but
i'm not the one to interpret his art
maybe he was right holding his head to
comfort him even though it was severed
he could have been cradling his head yes
ah and killing could mean
cuddling yeah the point is who are we to
tell kanye what his art means to him
yeah i don't think i don't i think this
is clearly overblown and i wouldn't have
him checked out for psychological needs
no not at all he's never been somebody
who thought he was christ no now i was
going to say he's also jesus yeah
well jesus jesus which i'm not sure if
that's just i don't fully understand it
either because then there's jesus and
then the shoes are yeezy yeah yeah it's
very expensive
but his life was never easy but it was
yeezy yeah and then he want he wants to
hear jesus in the clubs yeah the point
is he's a good christian man who would
never kill pete davidson so you know
what you shame on you hey hey gerald i
don't know do you see this what yeah
this is the plank in his eye
still trying to get that speck out of uh
out of yeezys i know the murder judgment
murder out of easy sorry it's some of a
different thing yeah all right hey by
the way speaking of performance art you
can follow uh the podcast if you're
subscribed here on youtube uh we're on
audio apple spotify as long as they
allow us android all that stuff used to
be called itunes when i was a kid really
what now it's time for a first fact
check of the day jyn saki i believe this
was yesterday maybe it was the day
before who knows at this point she was
responding to um mr chinless pete ducey
saying that the high gas prices are
actually the fault
of vladimir putin it sounds like you
guys are blaming putin for the increase
in gas prices man owns no chin gas price
is going up anyway because of
post-pandemic supply chain issues
well i think there's no question that as
we have seen outside analysts have
conveyed this as well the increase in
the anticipated continued increase which
is i think what some of your colleagues
were asking about that that is a direct
result of uh the invasion of ukraine and
also there was an anticipation of that
uh that was that uh was uh was factored
in as gas prices have gone on oh so you
were anticipating the so you were
anticipating the surge in gas prices
because of russia and the ukraine and
the way you anticipated it was by
forcing the prices of gas prices to to
rate i'm just want to make sure i'm
understanding this she was anticipating
it so gas prices went up well before
this right
oh so she thought there was going to be
a bloodbath so they anticipated the gas
prices yes instead of stopping the
bloodbath she's like a right she's like
a ginger oracle yeah the spartans
consulted her before thermoply i started
talking to neo earlier yesterday i think
it's thermopylae right what did i say
thermo
thermopylae i don't care
what am i thinking i don't think of all
clad thermoply pots and pans i just got
a new there you go just got a new set
about the copper and the aluminum
that heats up quickly
lifetime warranty they're not a sponsor
at all i'm just very thrilled about my
new pots and pans that's not a joke all
clad you get kind of excited it's
unbelievable how much better by the way
people out there if you don't know the
difference between buy your pots and
pans once and buy right it makes all the
difference in the world
i have no idea how much commercial i
have no idea how much non-stick
cancerous coating i've been swallowing
over the years oh most of it better than
paying too much for gas so let's get to
this the gas prices okay sure they've
surged obviously now because we
understand we understand the necessity
of reducing our dependence on foreign
oil we get that prices have gone up
significantly yeah since the crisis but
they were going up for a long time for a
long time i mean since about january
2021 something like that roughly yeah
rough end of january ish end of january
ish ball park fake someone closed the
pipe i don't know yeah i have no idea so
when biden took office 14 months ago
former vice president joe biden the
national average uh gas price was 239 a
gallon february 7th prior
to satan incarnate himself putin
invading ukraine the national average
was 344. that's more than a dollar
that's a lot of sense
i don't know if you know how many cents
are in a dollar it's about a hundred i
have to consult the oracles before
thermoply sorry
she don't make any she don't make and
you know what the dollars don't make
sense that's right now when she talks
so uh by the way in 2019 it was two
dollars and 26 cents oh wow so it was
2.26 cents in 2019 and then right as
fiden took office it was about 239
that's not that's less than a dollar if
you do way less
and now today it's four dollars and
seventeen cents four dollars and
seventeen cents that's the national
average we'll get to it a little bit in
california it's basically seven dollars
it's very close on some of the highest
end
good
so here's the thing yes gas prices are
going up and some people are trying to
say it's overblown uh no look i don't
know if you understand that uh the price
of energy affects everything that's not
just gas right gas is a reflection of
petroleum in general of energy in
general across the globe and that will
be reflected in the prices that you have
to pay at the grocery stores for um
anything everything from your frozen
fruit to your beef to whatever the hell
it is that you guys buy at whole foods i
don't really know i'm always confused
when i go into the aisle at whole foods
there's no idea yeah i don't get it i'm
like are you is this an ethnic store
like what are you trying right yeah like
pick something is this a spice is that a
health spice rack what are you i don't
know but either way i'm leaving with
chia seeds i just have a quick question
here 80 dollars more than it should be
so they had their uh crystal ball into
the future they saw the ukraine thing
coming they knew there was a lead up to
it that was increasing gas prices
correct and they did
to stop it like to not to stop russia
invading because they that was probably
going to happen anyway but just to do
something to mitigate the increase in
gas prices there was some big thing they
did right uh raised them yes
but and i know by before you send the
tweets i'm not saying that the the the
president sets the gas prices i'm just
saying that the president sets the
energy policies of course affect the gas
prices yes by the way in case you doubt
me uh read the green new deal it's like
a page and a half it doesn't take that
long to understand this is all about
climate justice when you un when you
hear this administration discussing gas
prices when you hear them discussing
wanting to move to green energy sources
understand that this is all about
climate justice reading the green new
deal these are the people who control
the democratic party when people say
they're extreme on both sides
not really not really when it relates to
energy read the green new deal and then
understand how scary it is that anybody
voted for it well no it wasn't if one
person voted if one person supported the
green new deal
that's one too many the fact that one
the fact that somebody even
without without stopping themselves put
quill to paper now this isn't a quill
but it's art but quilted paper aoc
wasn't it yes it was her and a couple of
others so it was cranda paper yes i was
trying to figure out the connect the dot
thing yeah the paper was cut with safety
scissors yes
scissors that also looked like two
crayons the fact that somebody actually
put pen to paper
and created
the green new deal and proposed it is
alarming enough look this is what i'm
saying i'm not even talking about you
know oh how a bill becomes a law i'm
going to sit in committee i'm talking
about before any of that just the green
new deal think of a thud bubble in my
head and
that's enough that's scary enough
aoc yourself should not have voted for
this well she was busy in her bomb
shelter of january 6th or something
telling everybody about her boyfriend's
feet yes well you all want them
you got it that's the problem dick
morris is like did someone say feet
i'll take two
so here's the thing just as we've
mentioned gas prices may have exploded
we all know that now
um of course a lot of people and
rightfully so and this is where we have
the disconnect this does affect the
working middle class this is how donald
trump won a state like michigan a place
like wisconsin the working middle class
because i think we're seeing again hey
remember when people thought the
democrats were not
looking out for the interests of the
american working class right yeah i
think we're experiencing that again
which is why there might be a there's
going to be a red wave the likes of i
mean it should be sponsored by tampax in
2022. geez
pearl ultra jumbo heavy fl so people are
upset about it here you go
people were feeling fed up about fueling
up at the pumps i just think it's
ridiculous that we're paying five
dollars a gallon yeah it's it's more
expensive than i've ever seen spader i
see it as an opportunity to capitalize
on a global tragedy and it's just
screwing regular people over who just
you voted for it i know you did the
conflict in ukraine has forced a sharp
rise of late but gas prices have been
steadily going up since the start of
2022.
since the beginning of the year crude
oil prices are up by about 50 dollars a
barrel
and that translates to about a dollar 25
a gallon at the pump does he really want
us to think that that's his office
window in front of the rockies yeah it
could be in denver in berkeley it said
berkeley who did it berkeley yeah
i just my office in front of a mountain
yeah that means look at my la if i pan
you can see all my books yes that's how
i know i'm a gas prices i used to appear
on fox news when i was at a studio it
was a green screen they go do you want
the cityscape or the library the books
like i don't know what do most people
get like well a lot of people ask for
the books because they want to seem
smart like books on a green screen makes
you seem smart
i'll go cityscape thank you very much so
we just talked about the average gas
price you know across the country per
gallon right now something like 417.
it's close to seven dollars i think it's
6.95 i'm rounding up you can admonish me
i don't give a rat's ass
here's let me put this in context and
people were talking about this on
twitter yesterday we were talking about
how we went back and watched like dumb
and dumber yes yeah and we saw the gas
prices and said like hey that's
basically the gas prices now the gas
prices now in california are so high
they are higher than post-apocalyptic
crappy film
i am legend
i'm a survivor
i am broadcasting on all am frequencies
that was supposed to be shocking
there's some consultant on there like
hey maybe we should boost it to 695. now
the keys has got to be believable it's
got to be horrifying enough that it'll
scare people but you just you can't you
can't show the monster right away yeah
don't worry it's still two bucks less
than mad max and book of eli
did they elect joe biden and i am legend
too
right before it happened yeah
okay
i believe the movie is about a vaccine
everyone got
the parallels are striking i'm just
saying i didn't write it's just a movie
yeah okay just a movie i'm referring to
the vaccine in the film that killed
everyone see dr fauci running around i
can fix this yeah exactly
one guy just gets shot by will smith
well okay well one guy and a german
shepherd are still alive yeah
where are the sand flies would you keep
the german shepherd alive i know your
idea what a liability that thing is well
historically you think you'd be mad at
them yeah you would think so too
well they don't have they don't have uh
i don't know what they're hiding there's
no shepherd he's got a shepherd i think
he has a shepherd in that right yeah
but there are no more fire hoses no
there's lunch
but the good thing is he can eat at any
lunch counter he wants yeah
the point is there's a silver lining
think about that for a second when we
say that it's beyond parody that's a
post-apocalyptic film yeah
yeah a group of people sat there and
were like look it you just can't get
higher than that nobody's gonna believe
it and people at the so that's like the
high end in what is it la county san
francisco kind of bay area yeah they're
looking at it
that's tuesday right
yeah
i saw that in the film once not even
once i saw that in the theater when i
was on the road doing comedy it's not
even an old movie
and by the way this is one of those
things where
if you were to say this like we were
talking about the consultant on that
film who was fired for being hyperbolic
saying i think we should make it like
750.
there might have been
if only there had been a world leader
who everyone accused of being hyperbolic
everyone accused of being uh you know
trying to induce mania who accurate
accurately predicted i sound like joe
biden right now huh
if only that like an oracle who
accurately predicted seven dollar gas
didn't do we haven't
and the lumber's gone through the roof
the lumber i guess as much as anything
but everything steel you look at what's
going on with pricing and obviously
you're going to have inflation
gasoline is going to stop at six seven
dollars
i think based on what i'm seeing we were
energy independent when i left and right
now i would have to say we are no longer
energy independent we're putting
windmills all over the place which
caused a fortune now i'm hoping he's
right in that it stops at seven yeah
well no with breaking news right now
they just went away from actually it's
still up there oh so on cnn bringing
this up really quick is about to
announce a ban on russian oil imports
okay so one finally yeah right and two
guess where gas prices are going now
right
where it would be one thing if they
banned russian imports and we said well
okay so that means that we're gonna be
able to use our own no oh no no we need
more green cars well what are we going
to do right now for getting rid of three
depending on the number used three to
ten percent
of the energy's oil production right
coming from russia uh sorry the the
world's oil production or the united i
don't know if it's our the oil
production or energy overall if it's the
united states depending on if you use
the global number it can be anywhere
from three to ten or just the united
states it can be from three to ten the
point is it's enough yeah it's a lot
it's one thing to say okay no more
russian imports which i i support yeah
but you can only do we just talked about
this yesterday so you're experiencing
this in real time so smash the like
button if you understand that you're
experiencing this in real time we
discussed this exactly yesterday
this just happened it is breaking right
now you can only negotiate from a
position of strength you're in an
entirely different scenario
on banning russian imports as it relates
to oil if you are energy independent or
relatively energy independent than if
you've been approving pipelines going
through their country and increasing
your dependence on oil coming from these
other countries who by the way don't
care about us hate us want to wipe us
off the face of the map or don't have
epa standards my point is you can take
any of those evils now here's the thing
far be it from me to defend
uh the oil companies on every level yeah
but i do think you know this is a little
they're palming it
they're palming it because right now
they want you to blame
one
they want you to scapegoat one person
right one industry and one only but the
thing is if we're going to blame the oil
companies like you just heard that lady
saying this is taking advantage of the
american people okay i understand that
who's taking advantage of the american
people we're gonna have some numbers
here in a little bit might shock you and
i grew up with this in quebec
so i'm right in there i went to
community college i know what i'm
talking about
um they want you to believe that it's
the oil companies exclusively raking in
all the dough just take it from this
black cnn host and bob newhart
you represent a district in california
where today according to aaa
the average cost for a gallon of regular
is
4.74 cents
is the administration are you is
congress doing enough to prepare the
american people
for the cost that may come as a result
of putting this pressure on putin
probably not enough but the american
people need to understand who is making
the big profit on the gas
right now i would call for congress
senate and house to conduct immediate
hearings on the profitability of the oil
industry there is clearly price gouging
going on here and they're going to wind
and say oh it's not us it's the
saudi arabians or somebody else but the
profits of those industries have gone
through the roof uh no we're not really
saying that it's a saudi arabian u.s
house member john garmendy
from california the worst state in union
we're saying it's you and this is this
is a solution they always have rights
well we're just we're going to look at
them and we're going to make sure they
bring prices down hey isn't that
strikingly similar to
something that former vice president joe
biden said by the way about inflation in
prices which only a month and a half
prior he said was a good thing but then
told you exactly how he was going to
bring those prices down same solution
i think i have a better idea to fight
inflation
lower your cost not your wages
huh
folks
i'm drunk yes
do you know how stupid he is he doesn't
realize what he said he didn't say lower
your price he said lower your cost yeah
which means they would make more money
right
because that's that doesn't have the
effect
one could almost argue go with me here
that businesses
are almost always trying to reduce costs
you know that's almost one of the
primary purposes of business is to
reduce costs don't go out and increase
profits yeah i don't think so
yeah just reduce your cost and every
business owner's like of course
why didn't i think of that
but also why does he need to fight
inflation inflation's a good thing i
thought remember we were we were told
inflation wasn't happening it was
overblown then we were told inflation's
actually a good thing
and then his solution was we're just
going to tell them to reduce your costs
oh oh well that's that's wonderful just
like with gas prices just reduce your
cost so here's the thing if you want to
talk about the american public the
working class being raped by oil
companies uh that they're taking
advantage of people during a pandemic
fine if you want to go that route okay
but you would have to place an equal
amount of blame
on the united states government i'm only
asking for consistency so according to
stillwater associates for every gallon
of gas consumers are paying about a
dollar and 18 cents in taxes and fees so
let me break this down for you in the
state of california where uh uh house
member bob newhart's from 18 cents in
federal taxes 51 cents in state taxes 10
cent sales tax 22 cents for the low
carbon program oh boy that's not an
umbrella term that can be abused 15
cents for greenhouse gas program
two cents for underground tank storage
here's the thing what
22 cents for a low carbon program
then 15 cents for greenhouse gas can't
you just bundle it and make it like
nothing well they can't label it slush
fund program right like it's well yeah
the low carbon program is just don't
drive yeah yeah don't drive your usual
route it's 22 cents where does it go
social security what about the social
security fund that's been going for a
long time what are you talking about do
i get that when i retire no no just take
it till you're dead so for every think
about this for every gallon of gas sold
in california uh the state
right takes a dollar
the federal government takes 18 cents so
that's a dollar eighteen okay if you add
up the oil companies together oil
producers refineries so oil produces
some like a dollar
anywhere from a dollar five to a dollar
fifteen call it a dollar twelve
refineries make five cents per gallon
those evil refineries tankers pipelines
make about one cents a gallon gas
station owners make about four to seven
cents per gallon in other words they're
both making effectively the same amount
they're both taking the same amount for
each gallon of gas you put in your car
so why
when why are we only blaming oil
companies and how
can gensake and joe biden and nancy
pelosi look themselves in the mirror and
say i know i'll vilify oil companies at
least these people provide a service
you've suckled at the government tea for
52 years joe biden
why aren't you just as responsible the
numbers are about the same this is all
i'm saying a little bit of consistency
if you're going to be mad at the oil
companies if you're going to be mad
certain or at the gas station owners or
the refineries you absolutely have to be
mad at the government and by the way i
lived through this in quebec yeah so in
quebec i don't know what the prices are
in quebec right now i bet you they're
higher than california a lot when i
lived in quebec we would go per liter
and um it was significantly more
expensive than the united states i
remember my uncle from wisconsin came in
and visited and he didn't realize that
it was per liter yes ah look at look at
that kyle look at that look at those
cheap gas braces there i'm like that's
per liter he's like what's a liter
we also have our bat we also have our
milk in bags you're crazy
yeah no the first time i went over there
i was like well this is nice yeah you
want to convert that just uh 2.3 times
that yes that's a gallon roughly so
people were so mad about paying such
high gas prices in quebec where i was
raised that um you know they were
constantly vilifying the old companies
and of course the local government and
the provincial government the federal
government there in canada the national
government they kept blaming the oil
companies and the oil companies and the
gas stations got so pissed off they
actually put at every pump a graph to
explain i think we have it yeah they put
up a graph to explain where the profits
actually went so kind of like now
they're really mad that there are biden
stickers being put up at gas pumps that
say i did that yeah
just just just tag a police precinct
you're better off than putting an easily
removable sticker at a gas pump the rape
is telling you about his childhood right
in a pie chart this is why i'm hurting
yes exactly right here oh thank you and
here's thirty percent of it that wow
look at new jersey gas price there 427
427 jersey wow and you're not allowed to
pump your own gas at least you weren't
new jersey when i uh lived in new york
you're still i don't think you're still
allowed to yeah because it could be a
fire hazard something like that oh what
is everyone doing in the rest of the
country what are we tap dancing at the
pump
what's up where they say yeah if you're
on your cell phone it could explode
really yes why is tim cook still free to
roam exactly how many lives has he taken
what because i get a text
i get a text on my phone now if
someone's going to look like dark man
i remember a guy came up to me in jersey
i was like is this the is this the
pull-up to the pump old days where you
come out and surf me on this side i'm
sorry i'll move my car and the guy's
like no you have to do it here
at your station really yeah and i'm like
yeah i don't think i don't think that's
right i don't think that's legal and
he's like nope it's all a jersey you ha
you can't pump your own gas and i was
like i'm qualified yes i can do it there
are a few things for which you are i
don't mind tipping i'm just saying i
could happily
you don't have to do this sir yeah but
he did he's like i do have to do it why
because once you create a law you can't
get it off the books even one as stupid
as this now we talked yesterday about
what we can do because there are
solutions that everybody out everybody
out there should know about i don't just
want to be a trevor noah john people who
just [ __ ] and don't actually offer
solutions uh barring of course a
solution of mandating vaccines for
everybody
we talked about fracking we talked about
opening up our own energy reserves in
alaska we talked about allowing more
onshore drilling leases okay we also
talked about the keystone xl pipeline
now to be clear there is some
misinformation going out and when i say
misinformation i mean people on the left
lying about this or misrepresenting it
and they're still free to uh post on
social media by the way uh the sitting
president president donald trump uh
banned as far as i know it putin may
still be on twitter
think so
cool
really
did you see there's a new twit someone
can bring it up i don't have this ready
here for the show but uh twitter said
that they're going to be removing any
posts that uh that so distrust in the
government of the ukraine why should we
trust any government let alone
let alone ukraine's government wow why
is that a policy so there's a difference
between keystone the keystone pipeline
and keystone xl now this was trending
yesterday and left us thought that they
really had a gotcha where they were
saying actually uh opening the keystone
xl pipeline won't do anything to lower
gas prices anyway and i think we have
some tweets up there yeah they were
trying to say that actually it's uh it's
a crude oil canada which is true and
it's crude and so they'll be selling it
to china or mexico now those contracts
don't exist these are people who are
effectively making assumptions which by
the way is also why keystone xl would
actually affect our energy prices
because the oil market is largely
subject to speculators yeah and if they
understand that there are more reserves
if they understand that there's more
access to oil you see a correction of
the market immediately so here's what i
was talking about earlier any increase
in energy production
will lower prices not only in the united
states it would be nicer to buy from
canada if we if we could to have that
option nope now i mean i don't you know
putin trudeau it's a toss-up it really
is
but trudeau won't be in there he won't
be there much longer he's not going to
invade anybody though no i have no idea
mounties come on i don't know maybe he
could he'd try he could try go for maine
be a great coup just lay low for 200
years
then attack honduras
just show up
take it like what did you see what
happened and show up in canada should be
like what i tell you and the hundreds
like was he talking to me i didn't even
know commander blackface what would you
say
yeah canada should just do that give
themselves like plausible i always
thought like i've never punched it i've
never know what it feels like to punch
somebody i can't stand in the face
because you know it's it's international
woman's day today's the best days ever
that tuna sandwich sucked
i'll never know what it feels like but i
always thought here's the here's the
problem with committing a crime
aside from the morality and the
punishment yeah is unless you're a
pedophile
ankle bracelet revolving door but is the
perfect crime is you have to commit it
against somebody who you have no
connection with that's the only way you
can get away with it but then you lose
the satisfaction and of committing the
crime against the person you want to
hurt and so it's quite the quandary but
i always thought that if i were if i
were to do it i would just i would give
myself plausible deniability like i
would punch some random guy but i'd yell
like stop eating my damn strawberries
and you'd be like what what did i do
who start were those his strawberries he
would have no idea and by the time he's
thinking about it going through
his memory rolodex as to what he did
wrong accepting partial responsibility
because it's a stand-up guy who i'm
punching i'm long gone
and he's waking up in a hospital yeah no
a belly full of strawberries and a face
full of tears yes and a mouthful of
teeth shouldn't do any of this so here's
a good example while we're talking about
this the keystone xl pipeline yeah sure
it's canadian okay got it crude i
understand it's not necessarily our own
oil immediately turn on the tap right
it's a part of a multi-pronged approach
fracking when we opened up our own
reserves it caused the global price
of energy of oil and gas to decline yeah
now keep in mind when gas prices were at
their absolute lowest right when you
were getting under two dollar gas here
in the united states you know as long
ago as 2018
the saudis and the russians they had to
flood the market to compete here's an
exact quote the saudis decided to flood
the world market with oil and send crude
prices from a 2014 peak of more than a
hundred dollars per bale to roughly 55
within a matter of months if i'm not
mistaken it's 200 per barrel right now
uh no i don't remember what the the
current price is but it's it's getting
close it's getting close to 200 per
barrel it's ratcheting up and this is
going to make it go up more you're 100
right this was economic warfare by
russia and saudi arabia because really
opec is really what you need to say
because those countries get together and
basically say that's not okay for them
to produce this much we're gonna flood
the market and make it to where now they
can't make money on oil and they have to
stop fracking so part of it was that
then right with policies from the
administration but everybody needs to
understand what we used to complain
about in the 80s and the 90s was opec
arbitrarily setting high prices for oil
because they could nobody else was
competing then we started competing and
it pissed them off yeah and it took
money out of their coffers and energy
prices for the globe exactly it doesn't
exist in this vac it's not an echo cha
it's not a closed-loop circuit put it
that way where people try and think if
the united states opens up their own
reserves that's the only thing that will
affect their oil prices no no if we have
more access to oil energy period
globally particularly if it's not coming
from russia coming from saudi arabia
coming from countries that hate us or at
the very least kind of hide their hatred
from us but are certainly not bastions
of human rights guess what prices go
down across the globe now we should
start with our own but that's not in the
cards right now for at least the next
two years uh oops that being said it
benefits everybody hey when you talk
about climate change you talk about it
killing people in the third world and i
know you want us to think that uh you
know the fact that there's some kind of
a fracking pipe going through an urban
area uh that has a you know median
household income lower than the national
average that's climate race race uh
racial injustice i believe
racial injustice or climate social
justice they make up a new term they
blend them every week you know what
kills minorities across this country
minorities to americans meaning people
handguns not white is uh
gas prices
it's inconvenient to you for it to be
seven dollars in california
it's deadly
it's deadly to someone in rural mexico
it's deadly to someone in south america
who works for two weeks just to get
enough energy to heat up a can of beans
the best thing we can do for the rest of
the world
is have access to as much energy as
humanly possible here in the united
states because at least we're dictating
the terms at that point but
you know look not at what the left hand
is doing it's the evil oil companies
it's the evil oil company that has
nothing to do with the government really
okay if you buy that well i have a time
share to sell you right i have a kenyan
prince
i love the bridge the comparison that
you talked about a dollar twelve to oil
companies a dollar eighteen to federal
and state governments yep they're the
same
if you hate one you have to hate the
other you can't split them apart i think
that was i didn't know that dollar
twelve two dollar uh dollar eighteen
yeah that's insane and if you add up all
of you know oil not just the old
companies but the refineries it's still
it's like a dollar thirty five but don't
worry the plan is going to be raising
taxes on people who need to pay their
fair share so they could just give money
away to people that they've raised gas
prices on that affected that are
affected the most by itself
don't worry yes in case you ever doubted
that they were out for their own selfish
interest uh this sitting former vice
president decided to race to he decided
you're like is it an arbitrary number
how is this determined out there what is
it out there in the e3 no we know
exactly who wasn't paying their fair
share really who's that anyone making uh
more than four hundred thousand dollars
a year what do you make four hundred
thousand dollars a year actually three
hundred ninety nine thousand nine
hundred ninety nine dollars now i just
passed that law okay
yes so his last dollar will be taxed at
that right highest marginal bracket i'm
paying it too folks we're all making
sacrifices that's 37 cents yeah well you
know i think crap never been there
and this brings us to also this
disastrous the foreign policy look there
there are a lot of concerns here when
we're talking about russia and we're
talking about ukraine it's not just
going on there now we should not be
going to war i just look i just don't
think we should be going to war in this
case because thousands of lives versus
potentially a billion when you talk
about even right the polish army talking
about sending in some fighter jets and
then uh some representatives in our
country are saying yeah we would support
that that's okay that's an act of war
then we're in war you're either all in
with war or you're not and i just don't
want to see more lives lost however
again it doesn't exist in a vacuum and
so there's a lot of this has to do with
well you were talking about this earlier
you want to talk about iran right this
is something with biden's policy and
iran and jin saki got really smug and
tried to blame donald trump for pulling
out of the iran nuclear deal uh but
really that's because it was a shitty
deal yeah well didn't stop them from
getting nukes and it didn't hurt them no
when you make bad policy decisions
domestically on oil production that are
going to affect the supply in the world
and also the pricing in the world it
forces you into some really bad
relationships and so right now we're
actually cozying back up to iran
of all people to go back into bed with
because what do they have that we need
right now oil right and we also talked
about maduro yesterday no we have that
they need bikinis
i don't know that they need them that
should be we are we only do business
with countries that allow the bikini
well when iran gets back to that because
they allowed it in the 70s and then they
became more radical then we'll sit at
the table and talk until then no nukes
mask is fine yeah well one of the people
someone's a little sexier when some of
it's covered up you guys remember the
yeah like a genie peeks the curiosity
again like i dream of genie i'll be your
darren i like shaq don't you need some
ocean front there i mean just in the
sand it's not going to work so you could
make an ocean they have man-made lakes
and bikes
you're talking like saudi arabia's i'm
talking about man-made lakes okay and by
that i mean slave-made lakes go ahead
right a lake not an ocean that would be
ridiculous well you guys remember when
we gave iran i don't know several
billion dollars pallets of cash kind of
the same thing that we did with
afghanistan except we just left it there
for whoever to take it right right we
gave them some money afghanistan it was
apache helicopters and blackhawks right
when he was actually the vice president
and they like the biden administration
sorry the obama administration
loved the fact that we were jumping into
bed with these guys and we entered into
an agreement with them
and gave them tons and tons of money
right now we're actually cozing back up
and trying to do that again and so iran
envoy uh robert maylie is close to
finalizing this deal with them and
giving them crazy concessions right i
think we have an overlay with it here
they're absolutely stunned by the number
of things that we are willing to give
away and the teeth that we're taking out
of some of the sanctions that we've put
on iran so former john mccain aide state
department official
gabriel naranja tweeted some of the
concessions i'll read them here for you
real quick my former career state
department nsc and eu colleagues are so
concerned with the concessions being
made that they've allowed me to publish
some details of the coming deal the u.s
has promised to lift sanctions on some
of the regime's worst terrorists and
tortures leading officials in the
regime's wmd infrastructure and is
currently trying to lift sanctions on
the islamic revolutionary guard corps
itself
that's insane you're basically trying to
get back into bed so they're talking
about the nuclear deal right that they
had talked about earlier they're
basically trying to make concessions now
to iran and get back into a bed with
them because we have an issue by the way
side note i don't remember how i think
it was saturday night we heard all
across the news that uh russia was
attacking a ukrainian nuclear power
plant yeah yeah yeah it wasn't a thing
oh the fire oh yeah didn't happen no ha
fake news huh what who would have
thought yeah
not me no he didn't say it i didn't say
it it was the news bring cnn up there
bring the uh bring the angry uh uh chain
gang lesbian cutted uh correspondents
there
look she's doing it look she has books
she has books those might be real she's
smart that may be real
scissoring for dummies we can't bring
the admonish over that but we should do
it
i can't believe i got admonished well
look so the iranian revolutionary guard
corps right so that name this you think
that's like their seal team you know
kind of sixth thing well general hussein
dagan who led the forces that killed 241
soldiers in 1983 in beirut will be free
of sanctions so that guy is part of this
uh sanctioned lifting that they're
talking about and the ayatollah khamenei
by the way oh i also believe is still
allowed on twitter also allowed the
companies uh the corporations that yeah
like i don't know if it's at a certain
point if it's a shell corporation or
like a like a a desert robe corporation
i don't know about the nomenclature it's
a golden parade uh it's gonna be worth
tens of billions yes tens of billions
because he's trying to compete with
putin for richest man on the planet yes
exactly he really gets to see right by
not starting an actual business himself
but stealing it from his people so these
are the people we should be in bed with
when doing this some people don't
understand i understand that when you
have enemies
you have to make alliances you have to
create alliances with people who are the
enemy of your enemy but when will you
learn it we should
iran's not a friend yeah stop trying to
make them a friend they're not your
friend you know what's really funny
though so iran and russia typically work
together to piss us off most of the time
right and now we're trying to kind of
with the nuclear deal we're trying to
lift some of the sanctions and start to
open some channels up and rush is like
no
no you can't get oil from them you have
to get it from us right so right for
political right they're trying to
actually stop the deal that we're trying
to restart with russia or with iran
right now i just think it's hilarious
like it just makes for very strange
bedfellows hello yes ayatollah khamenei
i hear that you might be talking with
the united states about well come on we
go back let's sit together at extra long
table to have talk you sit on that end i
will be over on the other end in three
days we will have two maxwell house cans
with a piece of string and you will hear
me crystal clear like we are on vonage
yes like movie big do they give you like
opera glasses as well yes exactly white
gloves yeah they're just binoculars
looking at each other talking through a
walkie-talkie yeah oh well look then
wilson's booth comes shoots you in the
back of the head all of this biggest
stable you ever seen all of this kind of
feeds into
something else that's pretty troubling
right with the u.s dollar let me explain
this on the outside before we get too
nerdy about it here's something you
understand the united states dollar
right is the benchmark right sort of
uses the international benchmark for
currency okay that's the preserved
currency reserve currency right if i
know that if i say the reserve currency
a lot of people like what yeah what no
look okay so it's basically the currency
that means by which all other currencies
uh are compared okay
you if you're watching right now
listening right now most of you the vast
majority of you but likely right now if
i'm speaking to you individually
watching listen you've experienced that
your entire life yeah and by that i mean
without a doubt you have
um yeah i'm trying i mean i don't think
we have any
120 year olds however long ago
yeah probably not
although if so thank you for your
service
so you've always experienced that you
don't know the cold world that exists if
that is not the case now we're at a
point with russia
and china we've talked about the
dangerous alliance that we could see
between russia and china but now india
might want to get into that mix so if
you have russia india china okay
that's half of population earth you're
talking about several billion people i
believe it's about half the population
if not it's very close is it 2.9 billion
i've heard numbers high like 3.5 billion
yeah well how many we got eight well
we're trending
we're losing so the point is it's too
many billions too many billions of
people if they are not if you if they do
not recognize the united states as a
reserve currency guess what that is a
huge problem for you that is the end of
the modern world as you know it and that
certainly is the end of our autonomy and
our freedom because that debt guess what
can actually be called in whereas right
now chattanooga is like hey you owe us
money we're not going to pay that yeah
we'll just print some more here you go
we didn't say it'd be valued the same i
don't understand what we tax i don't
understand why we increase taxes at all
or pay any debt with dollars that we
have if we're just going to print more
just do it all the time well you just
don't want runaway inflation well no i
know but they don't care about that well
they're turning our dollar into the
rupal yeah that's a good thing
inflation's good for the economy
according to joe biden right if you're
just gonna leave billions of dollars
worth of planes in the middle of the
desert perhaps too expensive to bring
them back is this former vice president
is he on live right now news right now
right now former vice president joe
biden is speaking live let's hear him
talk tough about russia we forward this
ban understanding that many of our
european allies and partners may not be
in a position to join us
the united states far more oil
domestically than all of europe all the
european countries combined ah thank you
in fact we're a net exporter of energy
and we were continuously we were oh
energy
as well what is that
our teams are actively just took one for
international women's day today he just
we remain united we ran united in our
purpose to keep pressure mounting on
putin and his war machine
this is a step though about the war
machine would you buy
putin
but there will be cost as well here in
the united states i said i would level
with the american people from the
beginning
he will level the americans he said
defending freedom is going to cost it's
going to cost us as well in the united
states
republicans and democrats understand
alike understand that
republicans and democrats alike have
been clear that we must do this
over the last week i've spoken with
president zielinski several times to
hear from him about the situation on the
ground and to consult
and continue to consult with ring ring
where's my kickback
about us
ukraine
ukrainian people big guy here thus far
we've provided more than one billion
dollars in security assistance to credit
shipments of defensive weapons are
arriving ukraine every day from the
united states and we the united states
are the ones coordinating the delivery
of our allies and partners of similar uh
weapons from germany to finland to the
netherlands we're a com we're we're
working that out
we're also providing humanitarian
support for you there's a word there
both of those still
we're safe
we're working that out working with
humanitarian organizations to surge tens
of thousands of tons of food water and
medicine
oh good well i guess the homeless
problem is solved here in the united
states we don't have any people going to
bed hungry i sent secretary blinken to
visit uh our border between these
buildings poland and ukraine blink
blinking dover
all borders matter now we don't care
about what's going on in our southern
border but we are obsessed with
ukraine's borders i just want to make
sure they understand the rules
he's the last guy you would want
in front of you or behind you at a
checkout line he doesn't know how to use
that little dividing stick
ordering russia nato countries and we
will keep our
guys in the express lane with 24 items
like you're way past the grace item
dummy vice president harris is going to
be traveling to meet with our allies in
poland and romania later this week as
well great i've made it clear the united
states
share in the responsibility of caring
for the refugees so the costs do not
fall entirely on the european country's
border in ukraine
didn't they just make it illegal for
able-bodied men to leave ukraine yes 18
year old men yeah that's always a good
sign by the way i just want to be clear
of course my heart goes out to all the
people of ukraine of ukraine of the
ukrainian russian conflict i know it's
ukraine not ukraine yeah it's very easy
to say because it's just ukraine sounds
weird coming out of your mouth my heart
goes out to those people but you really
are looking at one corrupt [ __ ]
fighting another corrupt [ __ ] let's
not ask let's not act as though ukraine
is a bastion of freedom over there okay
if you have to ban your own citizens
from leaving your country that means
that a good portion of them don't want
to stay and fight because they don't
think what you've created and by you i
mean of course as well the obama
administration uh the administration
that you've installed is worth fighting
for can you imagine having to ban
americans yeah
from fleeing the country if there was a
home invasion
no they have the opposite problem that's
why they're constantly concerned about
americans with guns because they know
they're going to plant their feet in
their soil and defend what's theirs
absolutely there are enough ukrainians
who don't want to defend that place that
they are trying to leave and a new law
had to be created to muppet hook them
back yeah major companies are pulling
out of russia entirely without even
being asked not by us over the weekend
visa mastercard america
they all suspended tell me when you have
diners club all of them yeah
jordan a growing list of american and
global companies from
ford to nike to apple they've suspended
their operations in russia
the u.s stock exchange has halted
trading of many russian securities
the private sector is united against
russia's vicious war of choice
the u.s department of justice has
assembled a dedicated task force to go
out yeah keep in mind russian crime none
of that affects vladimir putin you said
you were going to go after oligarchs you
think he's driving around in a ford
fiesta with his nike kicks
maybe
on an off day
he's thumbing through the roughly 800
million dollars that we've bought in
russian energy since the start of this
war going that's doing just fine
since putin began his military buildup
on ukrainian borders just since then
the price of the gas at the pump in
america went up 75 cents
because with this action it's going to
go up further
i'm going to do everything oh goodness
what a good
action in coordination with our partners
we've already announced that we're
releasing 60 million barrels three days
of oil from our joint oil reserves so
half of that 30 billion
million excuse me is coming from the
united states
and we're taking how about opening up
some new ones reliable supply of global
energy
i'm also going to keep working
with every tool at our disposal protect
american families and businesses
now
let me let me say this
to the oil and gas companies and to the
finance firms that
real time we understand putin's war
against the people of ukraine is causing
prices to rise we get that that's
self-evident but
but but but
it's no excuse to exercise excessive
price increases or padding we just gave
you the numbers
he's vilifying he's vilifying companies
that take the same amount or less
depending on the state
that this government takes think about
that for a second the difference is he
has a forced platform where you have to
sit here and watch and everyone has to
turn to this and act like he's not
spewing [ __ ]
oil and gas industries that are pulling
out of russia he's as close to literally
pissing on your forehead and telling you
that it's raining that i've ever seen
make sure we're not and i get that it's
figured i'm pulling a condom well look
let me be clear
about this
isn't a diaper he's wearing it's simply
not true that my administration or
policies are holding back domestic
energy production yes it is it's simply
not true yes it is even amid the
pandemic companies in the united states
pump more oil during my first year in
office than they did during my
predecessor his first year
because the first year
first year the first year what about the
other years production next year
in the united states
90
of onshore oil production takes place on
land that isn't owned by the federal
government
and of the remaining 10 percent that
occurs on federal land the oil and gas
industry has millions of acres leased
they have 9 000 permits to drill now
they could be drilling right now
yesterday last week last year
they have nine thousand
to drill on shore that are already
approved
so let me be clear
let me be clear yeah how many did he
approve do we have that number how many
uh former vice president joe biden
approved for onshore i believe it was
zero second i don't know i believe it's
none good number if not it's pretty
close to our economy over the long term
we need also here's a question
energy independent thanks joe yeah
wonderful tell me we're going to talk
about green energy okay then i want to
go back to that point themselves off of
russian oil
it's just not it's it's just not tenable
it should motivate us to accelerate the
transition of clean
energy this is the perspective of our
european allies share
what about nuclear future where together
we can achieve zero on surely
wow
regulations they just took credit for
energy investors that already existed
under president
but transforming our economy to run on
electric vehicles powered by clean
energy with tax credits to help american
families okay a couple things here by
the way right now we cannot power
electric vehicles on clean energy you
are many many decades away from that
also you have to understand the millions
of lives lost during that transition
because guess what the amount of lives
lost per kilowatt hour if you look at
things like solar if you look at things
like wind
the safest energy as far as human
sacrifice as far as the casualty rate is
nuclear something that they've something
that they have ardently fought against
for a very long time here's something
else too this is happening in real time
we just were going through yeah what
this administration is doing and they
did it right now all references
available at loudoutcredit.com
but i want you to let's do this exercise
okay right now and you know what let's
have the team ready here to to fact
check it so that i make sure i'm not
speaking out of turn because i'm not
prepared for any of this
but he just sold you he said look look
at all these uh look at all these uh
they have these leases and they're not
drilling they could be drilling right
now okay good so it's a company that you
just vilified for being greedy and
wanting to make a profit you just
vilified them for being greedy
profiteers right everyone remembers that
okay so assuming that they are the
greedy profiteers you made them out to
be
why would they not be drilling
their business
is providing oil
seems to me you need to drill seems to
me that the primary right the primary
actions you need to take in order to be
a successful oil company is to first
procure the oil
and then
sell the oil uh-huh yeah why would they
not be procuring the oil
what would be the answer to that again
this does not pass a sniff test either a
it's completely false or b and this is
why i said this doesn't exist in a
closed-loop circuit oil companies were
afraid
to open up more drilling because of what
they saw happening with this
administration because they saw the
taxes increasing because they saw that
it would be less profitable and not to
mention we had an economic shutdown that
had people traveling at record low
levels all of which is a direct result
of this guy and his ilk
why would they not be drilling
if you assume that they're corrupt and
they only care about making more money
then you have to ask why would they not
do the one thing that would make the
money oh unless this guy's going to make
it so that they can't make money and
guess what happens
that cost gets passed on to you
is he is he saying anymore yeah let's
here
he's mumbling
demented old circus monkey that's clear
they'll defend their freedom
their democracy their lives
and we're going to keep providing
security assistance economic assistance
and humanitarian assistance we're going
to support them against tyranny
oppression
you mean like lockdowns and mandates
people everywhere and i i think it's
maybe even surprised some of you all
people everywhere
are speaking up for freedom
when the history of this war is written
not everywhere putin's war on ukraine
will have left russia weaker
and the rest of the world's stronger
and god bless all those heroes in
ukraine and now i'm off to texas thank
you very very much i know there's a lot
of questions
he's always confused here because
you know they tell me i shouldn't answer
but i feel like i can do it there's a
lot more i can ask to be making
people yelling about more information
thank you i appreciate it hold on can i
just recap one thing that we just heard
a second ago please do gerald because
i'm angry i know you're angry and this
this kind of pisses me off a little bit
too but he he laid out the problem the
gas prices are high right now and
they're going to get higher okay you're
nostradamus got it right
your solution that you just said here's
what we're doing we release 60 million
barrels of oil three times from the
united states
30 million came from our reserves 60
million globally right that is
roughly
two days of operation for the united
states and china
period the top two oil consuming
countries about 32 million barrels a day
that's your solution to the problem no
you forgot uh more uh more uh pre-assist
no no the other part of his solution was
blaming people
for making any money as an oil company
for selling it right now and raising
their prices as price goes up and then
the third thing was go out and buy an
electric vehicle okay so everybody in
america right now should go out and
spend an extra 50 to 60 thousand dollars
on a car when they already have a car
yeah how many years is it going to take
to get that money back on the gas
savings hey i don't know like 20. do you
know what's worse for the environment uh
if you currently have a car and you are
currently driving that car a car you
already own yeah uh
you know what's worse for the
environment than to continue driving
that car buying a new car
it's better for you to drive that into
the ground than buy a new electric
vehicle if you want to do it because
they're fun and they're fast i get it i
wrote the tesla thing very cool very
cool awesome there's some pretty cool
cars and i also like that they're made
here in the united states and that elon
musk left california who by the way also
tried to force a transition to green
energy think of that for a second elon
musk is there anyone who's done more for
green energy or energy advancement
certainly as it relates to the
automobile than elon musk and he had to
leave california for texas that should
tell you how this ends
that's incredible that's our government
folks well it's a tax credit telling you
to spend 60 000
on a car which is worse for the
environment than just driving your car
into the ground the best thing you can
do is just not purchase a new car keep
driving that one i don't but the idea of
collapsing an entire country well the
world for two years and then saying you
need to go out and buy all this stuff is
astonishing to me the disconnect between
the rich ass politicians and everybody
else in this country is insane to me
you don't need to be a crazy conspiracy
theorist to understand the great reset
let's just go through these steps here
okay we have inflation first off he lies
and he says there is no inflation then
he says well inflation doesn't really
matter uh then he says that's a good
thing then he says well i'm going to fix
this by
keeping costs down okay well let's even
go back before that before we had the
inflation we had an economy that was
shut down artificially because the
government effectively punished
companies and we also had people who
were getting wages they were encouraged
not to work so we had a low labor force
participation rate we had an incredible
jobless rate by the way we still have
not added one new job since our peak of
2019 not one over that just to be clear
so we've not added any new jobs we've
had a net loss of jobs we have record
inflation and by the way all this was
created by the people who are here to
help the government their solution now
is we're going to force prices to be
lower by the way prices that you can't
afford regardless even if we had the
power to force them to be lower we're
going to enact energy policy under the
guise of climate justice that will
he just said it i'm not straw manning
him here you can rewind this 85 seconds
where he said the price of gas the price
of energy ergo all goods and services
that used in your daily life will go up
while trying to
force you to buy or encourage you to buy
cars green cards which are
unbelievably more expensive than the
average vehicle and certainly your old
beater that you're driving this is the
solution at this point and then vilify
oil companies oh and by the way we also
just declared blackrock too big to fail
that's what elizabeth warren was pushing
for who's a 10 12 trillion dollar
company how much are they right now it's
definitely 10 trillion or above
who are buying up all the real estate so
that they can create a permanent
renter's economy because you will own
nothing and you will like it everything
will be out of reach you can't afford it
they'll try and provide a credit so that
you can maybe try and put yourself into
more debt to purchase a new car that you
don't need while you're renting from a
house that is uh being leased by one of
the world's not one of arguably the
world's most powerful company that has
ever existed who by the way are
guaranteed
by you the taxpayer doesn't matter if
they go bankrupt and billy up you're
going to bail them out anyway
you will own nothing and you will like
it as we fight for freedom of
ukraine
send our boys to war to fight for
freedom and to fight for freedom in this
ukrainian conflict yeah that's what we
got to do that's okay you mean free what
is freedom let's define what freedom is
can we define what freedom is
the freedom to travel
the freedom to purchase any goods and
services that you want provided it's not
harming anyone else or that it's illegal
the freedom to choose what goes into
your own body the freedom to as an
employer allow your own employees to
choose what goes into their own body
think of how bastardized that is when
you talk about an employer mandate it's
not only forbidding people from choosing
what is forcibly injected into them it's
actually telling employers that they're
not even allowed to permit their own
employees to make their decisions you
will own nothing and like it you will
have no freedoms and like it and we'll
send
the rest of our soldiers off to fight
wars
in which we have no vested self-interest
this is the best and brightest this is
what you voted for everybody who voted
for joe biden right now because they
didn't like mean tweets
this is what you get
yeah not only that this is what you get
when you take a permanent ruling class
of people who've been a revolving door
of academics and those in government
when people always say oh i like
intelligence oh don't what we don't want
intellectuals running our no you know
what no no
because joe biden is considered an
intellectual why because he went to a
good school
allegedly and then has suckled at the
government tea for 48 years you know
what i would sooner take a plumber who
created his own business
a successful business who started as a
contractor and created a business and
went through that life experience
who actually wrote
his name on the front of checks not just
the backs of them i would sooner take
that man as president than someone like
a president joe biden or god forbid
former vice president joe biden or god
forbid a president uh kamala harris
whose greatest qualification was opening
her legs for a mayor
some very serious topics and everything
let's let's talk about that either
behind these into weed and blenders yes
is that a big one let's either talk
about that behind the paywall or
tomorrow i want to i want to make that
macro point about driving india russia
china together in kind of this new world
what do i need to bring this up here to
follow you because i just we'll talk
about that tomorrow can we talk about it
tomorrow yeah i was going to say because
this just happened live and i think that
we just hit what we need to do right you
just experienced this in real time
yesterday go watch yesterday's show this
is an exercise that i want everyone to
do if you can if you if you care about
this program at all or if you want to be
able to defend when people say oh dave
and i make offensive jokes uh look go to
yesterday's show
watch what we discuss we discuss energy
we discuss energy policy we discuss
energy costs
and we discuss what was most likely to
happen then today
we showed you their playbook and not six
minutes later
they came up and used it that's what
changed my mind is that's why we do this
show that's why all references are
publicly available at lateralcredit.com
it's not about a tit for ted it's not
about a quadrant view with people who
look like they're from lemony snickets
on cnn scoring a few points it's about
learning how to think
if you can learn how to learn if you can
learn how to think that's why i wanted
to go through that in real time wait
hold on a second
they have all of this access to oil
these evil profiteering oil companies
but they're not drilling why
if i serve no other purpose for the rest
of my life and they are few and far
between
it is hopefully that you learn how to
not only think but learn how to learn
and everyone learns differently
but it starts with looking at everything
that is being fed to you especially
through authoritative figures
through a critical lens and asking
why
why
like a four-year-old why
why
why
it starts with asking why if you ask why
to everything he just said
well guess what you'll find the answers
in two shows here within the last 48
hours we're about to go discuss uh
pedophile vigilantism not pedophile
vigilantes oh that's terrible different
no vigilantes against pedophiles yeah uh
smash the like button leave a comment
as to
what you think the y is below that's the
best thing you can do for the youtube
algorithm which doesn't like us anyway
they're not paying us anything all right
youtube we're about to go discuss
something that i know you hate
our dislike for pedophiles uh
sorry i mean half your staff piss off
youtube